as part of its mission to engage people
in the months running up to the European
elections the european parliament has
officially launched the european youth
event 2014 the goal is to invite five
thousand young people from the 28 EU
member states and its neighbors to go
behind the scenes of the European
Parliament this will include an
informative guided tour it's no easy
task to get young people interested in
2009 just 29 percent of people aged 18
to 24 cast their vote it's not ok number
really have to do something and that is
why the European Youth Forum together
with ID on world watches having this
project League of young voters it's
aiming at informing and empowering young
people to vote in the next European
Parliament elections will these efforts
be enough to make a real difference to
voter turnout we asked one MEP who's
been leading the project VIP Vivian nima
dental activated depot blame Alison sand
and vamoose islands are best escaping in
politician in height in the beginning
with you can't laying in the transparent
some sort of politic in the dirt so
confront worked on among the topics that
will be grappled with will be youth
unemployment the digital revolution and
the future of the European Union itself
these discussions may well provide much
food for thought for EM eps we are I
told Bob Warner the warranties ooh Lord
soon via zinta of agribusiness guard
even mentions ish meeting indian aunty
loser was for slaying Trudy and week
long or puzzled react well al Augie you
know the fasten a page on Parliament's
website dedicated to the event has been
set up for young people aged between 16
and 30 and is eagerly awaiting you to
sign up in groups of 10 at a time